[Musique]
si vous en doutiez encore frottez vous
les yeux et tendez l'oreille vous serez
alors que les sorcières du Berry ce
n'est pas une légende aïe la sorcière de
la nuit
les sorcières à bonus petits villages au
confins du bois chaussures on y croit
tant qu'une maison leur est dédiée on y
apprend d'authentique histoires de
sortilèges dont certaines des frais
toujours la chronique là nous sommes
dans une scène qui représente le
boulanger un boulanger de Lourdes ou Aix
une ville un village des environs qui
avait constaté que son peine ne levait
pas là il a soupçonné l'autre boulanger
de la commune d'être une sorcière et de
l'avoir ensorcelé il a fait appel à des
à des sorciers du cru pour lever
l'emboutement des leveux de sort comme
on disait mais ça n'a pas marché plainte
à la gendarmerie c'est autre tableau
figure le prêtre chasseur de sorts et
c'est là toute la magie de la fête de
bonus où se disputent en bonne entente
les Furies et les anges ceux qui guident
les pèlerins sous la bienveillance des
sorcières grâce auxquelles cette
ancienne procession peut à nouveau avoir
Lyon c'est une fête votive où on sortait
Saint-Luc et
faisait une procession
cette procession n'étant plus la fête
évidemment a coulé un petit peu si on
peut dire donc avec un groupe d'amis
nous étions 4 a décidé de refaire cette
procession qui redonnerait sans doute
vie à la fête
faites auquel on aurait rajouté un brin
de un petit piment qui serait la
sorcellerie du piment une pincée de
poudre de perlimpinpin sur une fête qui
rassemble chaque année près de 5000
accrocs aux sorcières bien-aimées du
Berry